et voilà c'était autisme le petit
chasseur de fantôme réalisé par le papa
de Tom qui est avec nous aujourd'hui et
que l'on vient de voir dans ce dans ce
film et qui nous fait l'honneur de
participer à Z la Zone d'Éducation
documentaire bonjour miik Mau merciation
merci ben merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous et juste à côté de vous nous
accueillons Fadila katabi bonjour vous
êtes ministre délégué chargé des
personnes handicapées merci d'avoir fait
le déplacement pour répondre aux
questions de la 3eA du collège Louis
Pasteur à Moré bonjour les élèves
bonjour Alors je sais que vous avez
plein plein de questions à poser à nos
deux invités mais juste avant de
démarrer moi je voulais savoir est-ce
que l'autisme ça vous évoquait quelque
chose en particulier Lucas l'autisme
c'est une maladie que certaines
personnes ont mais qui n'est pas
transmissible à la naissance bien sûr
donc bah c'est une forme de handicap
aussi qu'est-ce que ça évoque pour vous
le mot handicap
oui dis-moi le handicap c'est c'est
souvent associé à au fait de pas pouvoir
faire certaines choses de de n'en être
pas forcément capable ou alors très peu
h h dans votre établissement vous avez
une classe ULIS je vous vois tous AC
quier qui peut m'en parler rose euh une
classe ULIS c'est une classe où c'est
des personnes souvent qui sont
handicapées Ben qui qui ont un programme
adapté euh pour leur scolarité du coup
par exemple mercredi eux ils n'ont pas
cours et dans certaines matières comme
par par exemple le sport l'art plastique
ben ils viennent dans nos classes ok
qu'est-ce que tu en penses bah c'est
bien parce que ça peut les intégrer avec
les autres élèves sans pour autant être
trop dur pour eux d'accord ça vous
arrive de jouer même avec les membres de
la classe ulice bah on joue pas mais on
parle voilà enfin ils sont normals oui
c'est vrai je dis jouer comme si vous
étiez des des enfants d'école primaire
mais non vous discutez vous partagez des
trucs quoi ok super c'est à vous
maintenant de de poser vos questions et
on va commencer avec toi on t'écoute
Agathe comment va Tom aujourd'hui alors
le documentaire on l'a tourné il y a 2
ans alors déjà Tom malheureusement il
aime plus les chemins de fer on visite
encore beaucoup les manoirs abandonnés
les châteaux tout ça mais les chemins de
ver c'est terminé il a remplacé ça par
les chiens euh il est passionné par les
chiens les races de chiens donc il veut
caresser tous les chiens dans la rue et
tout ce qui est un peu fatiguant des
fois parce qu'il faut s'arrêter très
souvent il y a beaucoup de chiens qui
sont promenés par leur maître et c'est
fatiguant et en fait Tom après le
tournage il était en école primaire où
il était très protégé dans son
établissement il a commencé le collège
et là ça commencé à être très compliqué
parce qu'il intégré aussi un dispositif
Ulis ce dont on parle depuis tout à
l'heure et en fait on pensait que ça all
être une victoire qu'ilinttègre cette
classe uliss sauf que il s'est
retrouvé en fait on lui a demandé lui de
beaucoup trop s'adapter à l'école et
l'école c'est pas beaucoup adapté à lui
en gros il a il a des difficultés à se
sociabiliser tout ça mais il a une
intelligence normale sauf qu'il n'a pas
assez d'heure d'accompagnement Tom il y
a des heures encore où il peut pas aller
en classe accompagné donc là l'école a
été d'accord pour mettre en place un
aménagement spécialisé pour Tom il ne va
plus à l'école les mardi après-midi et
les mercredis matin pour ne plus être
stressé parce qu'il a pas
d'accompagnement mais par contre il nous
demande et surtout il lui demande de
rattraper lui-même les cours donc il
doit écrire à élèves de sa classe les
soirs pour rattraper les devoirs et
après il nous demande à nous de lui
faire l'école les mardi après-midi les
mercredi matin on travaille on est
débordé on sait pas faire aussi tout
simplement moi là on me demande de lui
faire les leçons d'histoire j'ai oublié
depuis bien longtemps je peux vous le
dire et c'est très compliqué donc il va
mieux il est plus angoissé mais en
attendant la solution n'est pas encore
adapté parce que il prend du retard un
retard monstrueux euh dans plusieurs
matières et je pense que ça va être très
compliqué de rattraper après on Contin
continuue avec Rose euh j'ai une
question pour madame la ministre
avez-vous vu le documentaire le petit
chasseur de fantôme et si oui qu'en
avez-vous pensé oui je l'ai vu j'ai été
aussi ému de voir effectivement la
relation entre un père et son fils en
situation de handicap et notamment ce
qui émanait c'était surtout l'inquiétude
d'un père quand à l'avenir IR de son
enfant en situation de handicap mais
malgré tout le documentaire j'allais
dire fait passer un message quand même
plein d'espoir et positif puisqueà
travers les témoignages
d'adultes on voit que même si on a en
situation on est en situation de
handicap on peut s'insérer dans la
société on peut apprendre un métier et
vivre à peu près normalement on continue
avec Lana j'ai une question pour le père
de Tom avez-vous rencontré des
difficultés pendant le tournage et si
oui
lesquelles
il y a eu des difficultés déjà d'ordre
administrative c'est-à-dire que pour
tourner au Danemark dans l'aéroport
ou en Israël avec une association en
lien avec l'armée ça a été de longues
longues longu longu longu
démarches d'autorisation de demande
d'autorisation c'est c'est très complexe
et ils ont demandé à regarder les images
qu'on avait filmé tout ça on a dû
leurenvoyer le film pour pour checker
flouter tout le monde ça ça a été très
compliqué et après pendant le tournage
ça a été la la fatigabilité des
intervenants c'est c'est-à-dire toutes
les personnes B déjà Tom mais toutes les
personnes que j'ai rencontré étaient
fatigué du tournage on a passé en
moyenne trois ou 4 jours avec chaque
personne est-ce que vous pouvez
peut-être nous préciser cette notion de
fatigabilité qu'on entend rarement
finalement qu'est-ce que c'est en fait
c'est bon déjà on les tous en soi mais
les personnes avec cotisme c'est
multiplié par 10 par 1000 parfois elle
fatigue très vite quand on leur demande
de se concentrer très longtemps sur
quelque chose là en plus c'est très
particulier parce qu'elle parlait
d'elle-même donc ell allent puiser dans
des des choses des fois qu'elles avaient
pas pas forcément envie de dire ou
qu'elle n'avait pas l'habitude de faire
donc ça leur a demandé beaucoup de
concentration et et pour tous les
intervenants à la fin de chaque
interview il y a eu un moment de fatigue
mais monumental où on n pas pu continuer
après en fait ça a été très compliqué et
eu et les les tournages c'est souvent
très rapide les journées de tournages
sont très remplis on commence tôt le
matin on finit tard le soir ça on a on a
l'habitude de faire ça sauf que là avec
tous les intervenants qu'on avait on on
avait pas pris en compte qu'on allait
devoir faire ces longues pauses tout ça
donc ça a vraiment modifié no nos
planning de tournage on a dû s'adapter à
eux ce que ce que tout le monde devrait
faire de toute façon pour des personnes
dans sitation de handicap on s'est
adapté à leurs besoins comment avez-vous
trouvé les personnes que vous avez
interrogé alors il y a eu deux méthodes
tu as la méthode un peu traditionnelle
journalistique où on a contacté les
associations parce que je sais pas si tu
as marqué dans le film chaque
intervenant a un lien avec mon fils une
passion en commun tu as hlad en Israël
qui cherche sur les cartes satellites
Tom fait la même chose Valérie au Canada
elle dessine beaucoup Tom dessine
beaucoup donc à chaque fois on voulait
que la personne avec Tom et après il y a
des des méthodes un peu plus rock and
roll pour Valérie par exemple au Canada
un soir j'ai tapé autisme graphisme dans
mon moteur de recherche et je suis tombé
sur Valérie dans les premières pages je
regarde je fais cette femme elle l'air
exceptionnelle et je l'ai contactter sur
Facebook comme vous vous pourriez faire
pour contacter quelqu'un j'ai écrit
bonjour Valérie je réalisé un
documentaire avec mon fils est-ce que
vous vous seriez intéressé pour me
parler elle m'a dit on peut faire un vis
demain matin dis donc elle est rapide et
là on a fait plein de Visio et de mois
après j'étais chez Valérie au Canada ça
sera une question pour madame la
ministre pourquoi avez-vous été nommé
ministre de du handicap déjà c'est une
belle mission il y a tellement de choses
à faire pour faire en sorte que la
société soit plus solidaire plus juste
que le regard des personnes sur le
handicap change et bien j'ai envie de
mener vraiment à bien cette belle
mission parce que il y a encore beaucoup
à faire si ce n'est que de construire la
société bienveillante pour ce qui est
pour ce qui concerne les personnes en
situation de handicap euh quel a été
votre parcours pour que l'on vous nomme
à ce ministère en 2017 j'ai décidé de de
soutenir le président de la République
et donc j'ai été député et présidente de
la commission des affaires sociales et
en tant qu'aussi citoyenne et en tant
que personne j'ai été aussi voilà
confronté au sujet du handicap je suis
sûre que partout ici dans cette salle on
est à un moment donné confronté voilà à
la situation d'une personne en situation
de handicap d'ailleurs on peut très bien
être né sans aucun handicap et devenir
après euh parce qu'il y a eu un accident
de la vie parce qu'il y a eu un accident
de la route et cetera et être en
situation de handicap je crois que tout
le monde à un moment donné peut être
concerné par par ce sujet on continue
avec
Lucas ça sera une question pour le papa
de Tom avez-vous rencontré ces
professeurs qu'est-ce qu'ils en disent
et sont-ils formés à ce type d'handicap
on a passé pas mal de temps à aller à
l'école pour Tom à rencontrer bah
surtout les professeurs qui lui posait
problème en fait et oui c'est sûr qu'il
y a un manque de formation des
professeurs Tom quand il y a un
professeur ave qui ça se passe bien il a
envie de travailler en anglais par
exemple en italien dans les langues il
adore et là là il y a pas de problème
mis à part des messages de la professeur
qui ça se passe super bien en anglais il
est bien en ce moment il faut qu'il
continue comme ça il il l' encourage
très souvent euh ouais malheureusement
quand tu rencontre les professeurs c'est
souvent quand ça va pas alors on profite
de votre présence madame la ministre
pour comprendre un peu qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça ce manque de
formation des professeurs je pense que
les professeurs vraiment ils veulent
bien faire simplement parfois ils
peuvent mal faire par méconnaissances et
donc il est absolument nécessaire
effectivement de passer par la formation
de renforcer justement la formation des
enseignants par rapport sur le sujet du
handicap mais je crois que c'est même
pas le seul métier hein il y a les aesh
les personnes qui accompagnent les
enfants en situation de handicap au sein
de l'école mais ça n'est pas suffisant
on est passé en 2017 de 49000
assistantes de vie scolaire à 136000
aujourd'hui aesh au sein de l'éducation
nationale et donc il y a les Aes mais il
nous faut aussi les professionnels
médico-social c'est-à-dire psychologue
pédopsychiatre ergothérapeute
orthophoniste et tout ça manque au sein
de l'école de la République Tom il a
écrit une lettre euh voilà que j'ai euh
que j'ai ici puisque c'est son papa qui
me l'a qui me l'a gentiment transmise
euh pour parler justement de ces classes
ULIS euh voilà il y a les les structures
Ulis l'inclusion évidemment mais encore
faut-il avoir les moyens nécessairirees
et le bon personnel pour pouvoir le
faire euh quelle était sa demande est-ce
que vous pouvez nous la résumer euh en
brièvement Tom avait trouvé son
équilibre en classe de 6e et et il y a
eu donc des nouvelles directives annoncé
pour son entrée en 5e avec cette
fermeture de classe
uliss de les deux premières semaines
après chaque vacance scolaire et aussi
une demi-journée par par semaine où les
coordinatrices de classe ulice vont en
formation donc en fait la classe ulice
elle est plus elle est ouverte que 21 he
par semaine et Tom il y a encore pas mal
d'heures où il se retrouve dans la
nature on lui a proposé d'aller en
permanence mais vous vous doutez bien
qu'en permanence avec le bruit tout ça
c'est pas possible surtout sans
accompagnement donc là Tom la solution
pour l'instant c'est de le garder à la
maison et Tom ça tom lui qui avait
trouvé son équilibre qui allait si bien
il il il a eu l'impression de se
retrouver dans la situation de l'année
dernière c'est-à-dire oh là là mais moi
je vais encore être être trop stressé de
me retrouver en classe sans
accompagnement je il avait une montagne
arrivver dans lui tous ses stresses sont
réapparus tout ça donc avec sa maman et
sa psychomotricienne et son
orthophoniste ils ont décidé d'écrire
une lettre mais c'est Tom qui a eu
l'idée et la lettre elle est vraiment
bourrue de BR c'estd que c'est Tom qui
l'a écrit personne n intervenu c'est
pour ça que des fois oui elle est très
on a juste l'impression que la class la
classe va fermer
définitivement par que ça ilexlique pas
mais en tout cas il il a compris de
lui-même aussi qu'il y avait d'autres
enfants dans sa classe qui vivaient très
mal la situation donc ça montre qu'il
comprend très bien aussi ce que
ressentent les autres ça c'est les
différents handicap d'ailleurs
par hand et en plus voilà la classe
c'est un repère pour Tom s'il a pas
cette classe c'est une catastrophe et ça
devrait être un repère ouvert en
permanence pour lui et c'est ça qui vous
ce serait se dire ok là je sais qu'il y
a la classe ulice si je suis stressé je
sais quoi qu'il arrive je peux y aller
et là c'est pas le cas elle elle est
fermée trop souvent elle manque d'ors
d'ouverture cette classe ulice et c'est
ça qui dénonce dans lare dans le
courrier donc cette lettre elle est
arrivée sur votre bureau et et donc on a
votre réponse évidemment parce que vous
lui avez répondu et vous parlez d'une
d'une priorité qu'est-ce que
concrètement là aujourd'hui vous pouvez
répondre à Tom bien sûr donc il faut
regarder bien sûr le le cas parce que
ils sont encore une fois plusieurs
enfants en situation de handicap dans
cette même classe ce qui ne convient pas
à th peut convenir à d'autres enfants
c'est ça c'est ça la complexité en fait
de de de de de de l'inclusion de
l'inclusion c'est du cas c'est vraiment
un travail de dentelle en fait c'est
c'est c'est compliqué parce que
justement il y a beaucoup de parents qui
demande à ce que l'enfant intègre une
classe ordinaire également ok donc ça
aussi ça existe bien sûr euh et et de
faire en sorte que l'enfant puisse aussi
voilà avoir des activités sportives
manger à la cantine avec ses petits
camarades jouer à la récrée dans dans la
dans la cour de récréation mais par
contre ce que ne peuvent pas faire tous
les enfants ou alors il faut le faire à
dose homéopathique donc tout ça c'est un
travail vraiment de dental donc c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que que cela
est-ce que l'inclusion a tout prix euh
et forcément la bonne ligne on sait
que tous les enfants ne pourront pas
suivre une scolarité on va dire
ordinaire c'est-à-dire 8h ou 6h dans la
classe avec les autres enfants on doit
toutefois pouvoir faciliter certains
temps c'est-à-dire peut-être que
l'enfant effectivement ne pourra pas
suivre une scolarité normale ou a besoin
d'être en IME donc dans des classes
justement adaptées uliss mais ils
doivent pouvoir peut-être faire à un
moment donné certaines activités en
milieu ordinaire donc c'est tout ce
travail que nous voulons en tout cas
mettre en œuvre avec Gabriel àel parce
que ça donne des résultats véritablement
on continue avec Léo qui est juste
devant est-ce que c'est difficile pour
to d'être dans le
documentaire est-ce que c'est vu alors
oui oui c'est vu alors il il y a des
petites phases rigolotes à à ce sujet
euh tom était content de faire le film
il a juste eu peur au moment donné de sa
sortie que les petites filles tombent
amoureuses de lui c'est le voyer dans la
rue donc en fait le film a été diffusé
sur la chaîne parlementaire donc c'est
pas TF1 en prime time donc pour le
rassurer enore pas encore enore je lui
ai dit je lui ai dit voilà c'est pas la
même diffusion quand même voilà en tout
cas non le seul truc qu'il avait qu' qu'
m'a demandé c'est de pas le montrer au
collège pour pas que les élèves
l'embêtent h ce qu'on a respecté sauf
qu'au bout d'un moment en fait ça se
passait tellement mal au collège qu'on a
fini par le montrer et ça a débloqué pas
mal de situations d'ailleurs déjà la
référente de sa classe uliss a dit ok je
comprends mieux Tom maintenant parce
qu'il y avait il y avait vraiment des
choses qui passait pas et donc ça ça a
aidé et maintenant il est conscient du
message que ça fait passer donc il est
content euh de savoir que ça peut aider
d'autres enfants et d'autres personnes
en sitation d'handicap moi j'ai
personnellement je l'ai trouvé vraiment
très naturel enfin il était assez à
l'aise est presque parfois plus à l'aise
que vous je dire bien sûr mais moi je
déteste devant la camérajà d'une part
non non puis puis en fait il se filme
tout le temps avec son téléphone donc il
a l'habitude d'être filmé il est très à
l'aise Tom realisile à quel point il est
différent
oui évidemment une question un peu
compliquée Tom il est complètement
conscient de son autisme il en parle des
fois il me dit lui-même quand il en a
marre j'en ai marre d'être autiste tu
vois donc il le sait très bien
maintenant en fait il le sait aussi
parce que les gens font en sorte qu'il
s'en rendent compte c'est le regard des
autres qui le met face à son propre
handicap si les gens ne le regardaient
pas un peu bizarrement quand il
faisaient des gestes ou quoi il s'en
moqueraiit complètement là c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est C là que je disais
qu'il fallait avancer c'est vraiment que
on tolère les personnes sitation de
handicap comme ils sont comme elles sont
Tom si on arrête de de lui demander
d'enlever son pinceau si on arrête de
lui demander d'arrêter il flappe flapper
les personnes dis souvent elles flappent
elles font des gestes comme ça pour se
détendre tout ça Tom des fois il a
besoin de le faire il se penche en avant
dans le film je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez je dis qu'il fait le pigeon des
fois quand il marche ça il le fait pour
se détendre et dans la rue pourquoi il
le ferait pas comme ça marcher comme un
pigeon en fait dès qu'il le fait les
enfants se moquent de lui tout ça et
c'est ça qui le envoie à son propre
handicap il faudrait que tout le monde
puisse faire ce qu'il a envie dans la
limite du raisonnable mais mais en fait
oui non il est complètement conscient de
son autisme et mais il veut faire
avancer les choses maintenant grâce au
film il sait que il peut faire un peu
évoluer les regards on continue avec
Rose qui est tout au bout on t'écoute
rose j'ai une question pour le papa de
Tom comment vevous réagir en apprenant
que Tom était
autiste du
temps au moment du diagnosticon il y a
une forme de soulagement parce qu'on
sait ce qui se passe donc ça ça peut
être le point positif entre guillemets
par contre après on est lâché dans la
nature c'est qu'on sait pas ce qui va
devenir de notre enfant et là c'est un
vrai parcours du combattant c'est très
compliqué et en fait finalement quand tu
vois le cheminement de Tom
et et tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
ensemble et B c'est super est-ce que
vous vous l'avez ressenti ça aussi en
regardant le documentaire je vous vois
aussi un peu ému parce que quelque part
on
partage d'ailleurs c'est transmissible
non mais voy bien sûr moi je me permets
de rebondir par rapport à ce que dit le
papa de Tom il a été diagnostiqué
l'enfant avait très tôt j'allais dire
c'est très important pour une meilleure
prise en charge de de de votre enfant
parce que il y a des personnes
aujourd'hui encore je les rencontre et
elles sont diagnostiquées très tard une
fois adulte c'est-à-dire 24 28 ans et ça
ça donne lieu à des parcours
complètement chaotiques il y a des
formes d'autisme invisible en fait aussi
c'est ça qui problè a des personnes qui
découvrent qu'elles sont autistes à 30
ans et en fait qui n'ont jamais obtenu
d'aide qui ont été en échec scolaire
tout toute leur jeunesse avec des
parcours mais catastrophique c'est la
raison pour laquelle le président de la
République il a annoncé une chose très
importante la création du service public
de repérage précoce gratuit parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des papas et des
mamans qui vraiment sont dans une grande
souffrance dans la mesure où elles ne
savent pas de quoi souffr leur enfant et
donc c'est très très important de
pouvoir effectivement repérer très tôt
pourquoi parce que ça veut dire qu'on va
mettre un diagnostic et accompagner
l'enfant tout de suite et plutôt la
prise en charge est mieux c'est pour le
parcours pour éviter effectivement
j'allais dire les surhandicap
s EXM important et not pour ce qui est
de l'tisme il faut véritablement poser
le diagnostic le plus tôt possible et
donc le service public qui s'adresse aux
enfants de 0 à 6 ans le plus tôt
possible et gratuit on va continuer avec
Anaïs on t'écoute dans le documentaire
il est dit que la France a du retard
dans la prise en charge des personnes en
situation de handicap que comptez-vous
faire pour remédier on est en train de
mettre en place le service public de
repérage précoce
sur la l'accessibilité aussi a des gros
moyens qui sont qui sont mis euh il y a
beaucoup effectivement de de jeunes de
jeunes adultes qui partent en Belgique
faute de de de place en institut donc
tout cela on va on y répond euh
véritablement il y a la deuxième
stratégie sur les troubles du
neurodéveloppement on y met 680 millions
d'euros hein pour apporter des réponses
en terme de prise en charge de repérage
et de développer l'école inclusive
encore une fois parce que il nous faut
aussi tous ces professionnels qui sont
indispensable pour accompagner de
manière qualitative les les les les
enfants et les élèves qui sont en
situation d'handicap au sein de
l'école on avance on
avance sur l'emploi je je vous l'ai dit
en terme d'insertion professionnelle on
était à taux de chômage 19 % 2019 on est
à 12 % nous avons 700 chercheurs
aujourd'hui sur sur le territoire et
vraiment une forte mobilisation sur les
sujets du des troubles du
neurodéveloppement donc on avance
franchement on avance et la France
aujourd'hui et bien elle peut être fière
d'être première en matière de recherche
j'ai une question pour madame la
ministre quel pays pourrait sair
d'exemple à la France concernant la
prise en charge du handicap on dit très
souvent ah la Belgique la Belgique
euh il y a des choses aussi qui se
passent pas très clair qui ne sont pas
très claires aussi en Belgique en
matière de prise en charge je le dis
franchement moi je me permets j parce
que j étaéis il y a 2 semaines en
Belgique dans ce festival spécialisé
handicap tous les belges présents qui
qui sont qui ont des enfants en
situation d' handicap qui sont eux-mêmes
en sation d' handandicap disent que faut
que les Français on arrête de dire que
la Belgique la Belgique la Belgique
parce qu'ils ont aussi beaucoup de
problèmes à gérer c'est très compliqué
voilà je rebondis sur ta question parce
que je pense peut-être que tu faisais
référence aux exemples très précis qui
sont développés dans le dans le
documentaire donc l'exemple israélien
bien sûr et même au Danemark voilà le
fait d'avoir des des programmes
spécifiquement adaptés où on met en
valeur ces talentl euh est-ce que est-ce
que ça vous fait envie j'en sais rien
est-ce
que an ah non non non mais moi j'ai mais
j'ai déjà croisé é changé des des avec
des adultes qui sont autistes qui ont
très bien réussi qu'on fait de
brillantes études non mais ça existe en
France également mais mais le fait
d'avoir développé des programmes
spécifique par exemple comme en Israël
est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
regardez avec une attention particulière
ou vous dites non c'est pas c'est pas
nous c'est que c'est ce que nous faisons
et actuellement avec tout tout
l'investissement dans la recherche nous
avons également une maison qui a ét ét
inauguré maison de l'autisme à
aubertvillier là aussi qui est vraiment
j'allais dire je vous invite à à aller
la visiter avec vraiment aussi des
réponses bien spécifiques et d'ailleurs
elle est de plus en plus fréquentée
notamment par les parents c'est la
première maison de l'autisme
desdialtisme en France donc non mais
franchement on avance on continue avec
Jan qui est juste là j'ai une question
pour vous Micke Mau pourquoi vous
acceptez de rencontrer des
élèves
en fait on a présenté le film à beaucoup
d'associations donc et beaucoup de de de
parents d'enfants avec autisme beaucoup
de gens qui ne connaissaient pas
l'autisme beaucoup de de spécialistes
aussi àve qui on a présenté le
film maintenant vous c'est une approche
complètement différente parce que c'est
un sujet que vous ne connaissez pas bien
et et c'est pour vous sensibiliser aussi
et vous dire de d'aller à l'encontre des
personnes avec en situation de handicap
je pense que c'est important que vous
compreniez que malgré leur différence il
faut les accepté et c'est dès maintenant
que ça se joue aussi pour que plus tard
ce soit complètement entré dans vos tête
et que on n pense même plus au handicap
au bout d'un moment tu vois que ce soit
et surtout il y a il y a un truc c'est
je vais peut-être plomber l'ambiance
mais en fait l'handicap risque de tous
nous concerner un jour on risque tous de
finir handicaper en étant très vieux par
exemple tu vois on risque de plus
pouvoir marcher tout ça donc faut y
penser qu'un jour nous aussi on aura
besoin de quelqu'un pour nous aider et
et c'est tout ça aussi que j'ai envie
d'expliquer et moi j'aurais aimé que que
quelqu'un vienne expliquer dans
l'établissement de mon fils euh ce
qu'est l'autisme ce qu'est le handicap
ça j'aurais aimé donc c'est un vrai
plaisir de de venir vous présenter ça à
vous
Oscar j'ai une question pour le papa de
Tom à qui est destiné votre documentaire
alors à tout le monde évidemment à tout
le monde moi quand j'ai eu le diagnostic
de Tom j'aiété complètement perdu je
savais pas comment on allait gérer cette
situation tout ça donc dans un premier
temps ça je je voulais montrer ça aux
parents d'enfants qui qui de en
situation de handicap qui connaissent
aujourd'hui la même situation que j'ai
connu il y a 14 ans maintenant Tom va
avoir 14 ans donc il a 12 ans parce
qu'on a le diagnostique à 2 ans mais
c'était pour leur offrir un message
d'espoir on comprend que chacun a eu un
parcours un peu difficile à l'école ça a
été compliqué tout ça mais ils s'en sont
tous sortis et ils ont fait surtout et
ça très important ou il ils ont fait de
leur différence leur plus grande force
c'est vraiment le message du film c'est
que c'est grâce à leur différence et à
leurs intérêts spécifiques toutes leurs
passion tout ça qu'ils ont réussi à s'en
sortir voilà continue avec Axel Tom
est-tu toujours passionné par les lieux
abandonné alors ou al oui oui Tom est
toujours passionné par les lieu
abandonné d'ailleurs en venant ici j'en
ai repéré sur la route tu vois un pas
loin c'est c'est vandô à côté tu vois il
y avait une maison abandonnée je l'ai
noté dans Google donc peut-être que je
reviendrai dans le coin dans pas
longtemps et on en a fait encore une
énorme visite la semaine dernière et on
on fait un château la semaine prochaine
et ce qui est drôle c'est qu'après la
diffusion du documentaire il y a c'est
une petite communauté qui s'appelle
lurbex les gens qui visitent des lieux
abandonnés et normalement ils dévoilent
pas leur lieu c'est secrets ça se dit
pas les lieux qu'on visite et tout mais
comme Tom ils ont été touchés par lui
des fois je reçois des listes de lu
abandonn j'ai rien demandé oh si toi
m'imes ça moi donc on a une liste énorme
de lieux à visiter des fois qui sont un
peu trop loin mais là on en fait encore
oua et il chasse encore les fantômes
avec son téléphone mais il en voit
toujours pas à la fin du documentaire le
papa de Tom a un message pour son fils
et l'AD aussi a un message pour Tom moi
je voulais savoir est-ce que Tom
regardera cette émission est-ce que vous
lui proposerez de regarder l'émission il
est au courant il est au courant tout à
fait ouais non parce que ça pourrait il
courant il il sait qu'aujourd'hui vous
répondez à des questions de d'enfants
qui ont il est prévenu il est
complètement conscient je lui ai demandé
ce que je pouvais dire pas dire tout ça
je lui demandé si lui avait des messages
à faire passer bon après non pas
spécialement parce que il connaît le
discours il sait de quoi on va parler je
lu demander s'il était d'accord pour
qu'on parle de toute la situation de la
classis tout ça lui il a envie que ça
avance donc oui pas de problème et il
regardera il regardera l'émission il
regardera l'émission ma dernière
question j'aimerais qu'on termine
là-dessus quel message vous vous avez
envie de de d'adresser à Tom qu'est-ce
que vous AZ avais envie de lui dire oui
dis-moi Naïs qu'il est super courageux
et je Saha tout le bonheur pour la suite
qui lâche rien qui garde qui continue
comme ça par il reste et qui fasse ce
qu'il veut faire et qui s'arrête pas au
regard des autres et qui faass ce qu'il
a envie de faire qui continue de de
croire que la situation d'handicap peut
avancer euh il a un papa qu' l'aime
voilà c'est un beau message un beau
message faire et vous madame la ministre
si si vous l'aviez en face de vous
qu'est-ce que vous auriez envie de lui
dire à Tom moi je lui dirais vraiment
d'avancer qu'il est entouré voilà d'un
papa en tout cas comme l'a dit la jeune
qu'il aime et avec beaucoup d'amour on
peut véritablement gravir les montagnes
et avancer en tous les cas moi je l'ai
trouvé plutôt solaire hein dans dans le
film déterminé volontaire
courageux qui continue bah qui continue
voilà surtout voilà voilà tout à fait
merci merci beaucoup merci à tous les
deux d'avoir participé à à cette
émission qui est déjà terminée on
embrasse Tom bien sûr on lui fait un
gros coucou un gros bisous bravo à vous
les élèves d'avoir posé toutes ces
questions de vous êtes intéressé à ce
sujet on peut féliciter vos professeurs
qui sont un peu derrière et qui vous ont
si bien préparé pour cette émission et
puis nous on se retrouve avec une
nouvelle classe et un nouveau
documentaire parce qu'il n'y a pas d'âge
pour questionner le monde et ses images
salut les élèves au revoirev bravo bravo
à T
[Musique]
bravo
voilà
l'espace et ben
voil